whether he's delivering one-liners
beating up bad guys or just looking
super cool
samuel l jackson has given us plenty of
pause-worthy movie moments
keep watching to see some of the most
memorable ones of his career
pulp fiction wasn't jackson's first
movie but it was the first time we saw
him at the height of his powers
especially in that scene where he
confronts a group of young punks
this moment is quintessential sam
jackson he plays a hitman named jules
winfield who works for the gangster
marcellus wallace
he and his associate vincent vega are
sent to retrieve a briefcase from brett
a petty crook who's trying to double
cross marcellus basically
jules is going to kill brett no matter
what but in typical hitman style
he must first scare and humiliate him
brett attempts to play off his betrayal
as a misunderstanding while he's trying
to explain his side of the story
jules casually shoots a man lying on the
couch naturally
brett is absolutely terrified but jules
doesn't offer him much sympathy
oh i'm sorry did i break your
concentration soon after the gunshot
jules starts interrogating a terrified
brett who can only bring himself to say
what every time jules asks a question
jules gets so frustrated that he sticks
a gun in his face
and shouts say what again say
what again i dare you i double dare you
you'll want to pause this fantastic
moment to appreciate every frame of this
darkly hysterical scene
attack of the clones disappointed a lot
of star wars fans but it's redeemed at
least a little
by the battle of geonosis in a coliseum
the villainous count dooku
stands on a high perch like a roman
emperor watching the execution of anakin
obi-wan and padme below him little does
duke who know though that an army of
jedi and clones are about to storm the
planet
and who should be the one to deliver
this epic news to him why none other
than jedi master mace windu
mae slowly walks up behind dooku and his
crony jango fett and then holds a
lightsaber to jango's throat
in classic mace windu fashion he gets
straight to the point by revealing that
there are jedis all over the coliseum
ready to battle the following couple of
minutes are possibly the most
action-packed of his entire jedi career
androids approach with guns forcing mace
to use his lightsaber defensively to
deflect lasers
jingle then sets mace on fire at which
point he jumps off the balcony several
stories down
while free-falling and on fire he still
manages to be awesome enough to continue
to deflect the lasers he lands safely on
the coliseum floor
tosses his burnt robe aside and then
goes absolutely crazy
he fights hundreds of droids dances with
a giant alien that looks like a rhino
and chops off jango fett's head you'll
want to pause several times to soak in
all the details
[Music]
nick fury has several great moments
throughout the films of the marvel
cinematic universe but one particular
scene sticks out in captain america the
winter soldier
normally fury takes on management
responsibilities and is rarely caught up
in firefights but fans get a rare treat
in winter soldier when he has to survive
an assassination attempt which features
sam jackson in full
badass mode the scene begins with fury
driving down a city block when a group
of cop cars suddenly slam
into him and pin his suv a dozen or so
policemen who are really hydra agents in
disguise
surround him and shoot up his vehicle
which is fortunately bulletproof
things get pretty intense but with the
help of his spy smarts and his suv's
artificial intelligence system
fury survives in the most awesome way
possible marvel fans get to see a whole
new side of him
as he takes out multiple hydra agents
with clever tactics and awesome
artillery
in addition to an epic fire fight the
scene develops into arguably the best
car
chase in the entire mcu franchise it's
epic
rewatchable and totally pause-worthy
in m night shyamalan's haunting
superhero tale unbreakable
jackson delivers a marvelous performance
as elijah price
a comic shop owner with a rare disorder
that makes his bones extremely brittle
when he was a boy other kids would tease
him with the nickname mr glass
as an adult he decides to find someone
on the opposite end of the strength
spectrum an actual superhero
he discovers david dunn a security guard
who's in denial about his incredible
abilities
even though he was the only survivor of
a train crash that killed over a hundred
people
but as the movie progresses elijah
persuades david to accept his powers
under elijah's tutelage david discovers
he has the ability to sense criminals
when he touches them
it seems like he'll become a real-life
superman with elijah as his mentor but
that all changes when david touches
elijah
it's at this moment that david learns
that elijah is a mass murderer who
orchestrated several massive
accidents like david's trainwreck in
order to find someone with amazing
abilities
after all if there's a superhero out
there it gives elijah a purpose in life
as a super villain david is horrified
but elijah is pleased that he's finally
found his place
he announces that he should have known
that he was a super villain all along
as the kids used to call him mr glass
give this moment a pause to really soak
in the chills
they called me mr glass
if there's one thing sam jackson is good
at it's yelling for the most
insignificant reasons and that's exactly
what he does in the other guys
the film is about misfit cops alan
gamble and terry hoyt who don't get any
respect from their fellow officers
conversely every cop in town admires
detectives pk highsmith and chris
danson as played by jackson and dwayne
johnson even though they cause massive
amounts of damage while catching
criminals
the relationship between the two least
popular and the two most popular
partners is a bit like the stereotypical
high school relationship between the
popular jerks and the pushover nerds
basically highsmith verbally assaults
them everyone thinks it's normal
and our loser heroes just take it on one
occasion
allen starts talking and highsmith
explodes at him
hey you shut your face if we want to
hear you talk
i will shove my arm up your ass and work
your mouth like a puppet
what makes this pause worthy moment
especially hilarious is just how
insanely
unnecessary high smith's response is
allen was just offering him a quick
compliment
but that's obviously not how it was
interpreted
in 2012's the avengers earth's mightiest
heroes find themselves fighting off an
alien invasion in new york city
unfortunately as our heroes are battling
the invading chitari
the mysterious world security council is
considering nuking the entire city to
contain the threat
and limit worldwide damage they hound
director nick fury to do the deed but he
isn't going to do that to his pals
let alone an entire city of american
citizens people he swore to protect
while higher-ups are pressing fury to
obey he drops this epic line
i recognize the council has made a
decision
but given that it's a stupid-ass
decision i've elected to ignore it
every military action movie has a scene
like this some big shot official insists
that innocence must be sacrificed but
the main characters instead defy the
orders and save the day
sometimes the right thing to do is
ignore your superiors
pause this scene and soak soaking the
hilarious disobedience to authority no
one does it better than sam jackson
people don't always talk that much about
deep blue sea but when they do
they always bring up one particular
unforgettable scene
because no one and we mean no one saw it
cometh
the sci-fi horror movie takes place in
an underwater facility that's in the
middle of nowhere
scientists are conducting research on
sharks which apparently has the
potential to help the fight against
alzheimer's disease
but like just about every cinematic
scientific experiment the specimens
escape
and start hunting humans it's later
revealed that the scientists genetically
altered the sharks to make them smarter
and more deadly
worse still the facility sustained some
serious damage and flooding
making it difficult to escape after
several hardships and deaths
the characters are at their wits end to
motivate them
russell franklin as played by jackson
gives a passionate speech about the need
for unity but right in the middle of
this inspiring monologue
a massive shark leaps out of the pool
behind him drags him into the water and
devours him
first we're gonna seal off
it's a bit of a shock on the first watch
but on subsequent viewings
it's a highly anticipated moment for
viewers and a favorite pause moment for
fans of creature features
in star wars episode 3 revenge of the
sith the jedi discover that
senator palpatine is the sith lord
they've been looking for
so mace windu leads a troop of jedi
masters to deal with him and as a result
there's a handful of pause worthy
moments in this one scene
there's the moment when mace first draws
his lightsaber announcing that palpatine
is under arrest
then there's the moment when he holds
his lightsaber over palpatine with the
massive cityscape behind him
but if we had to pick the best moment
overall it would have to be the
lightning kill
first let's give a hand to mace for
defeating palpatine in a lightsaber duel
that's a difficult feat considering that
palpatine is arguably the strongest sith
ever and mace would have finished him
off if it weren't for a whiny and
mislead anakin skywalker who chops off
mace's arm before the jedi knight can
deliver the killing blow to palpatine
this gives the sith lord the perfect
opportunity to electrocute mace
sending him a million feet into the air
we hated seeing such an awesome
character go
but we have to admit that it was one of
the most creative deaths in star wars
history
sometimes you get so angry with a
situation
that you just have to shout that you've
had enough and do something
absolutely bananas that's what sam
jackson does in this pause-worthy scene
from snakes on a plane
he plays neville flynn an fbi agent
tasked with safely transporting a
witness who is testifying against the
gang boss
but naturally enough the gangster has
arranged for a crate of deadly snakes to
be released on the flight
as you can imagine the snakes start
claiming victims and the passengers
become hysterical
they block themselves in a separate
cabin using luggage but it doesn't do
much good
it becomes so frustrating to eliminate
the snakes that flynn gives a heated
speech in which he unforgettably
declares
i have had it with these snakes on this
mother
then flynn starts opening up the windows
via gunfire like a madman
this scene demands to be paused to soak
in the catharsis
jackson has a way of delivering angry
lines that all people can relate to
granted not everyone is literally
fighting snakes on a plane
but we can all think of frustrating
situations where we want nothing more
than to give a good one-liner as
confidently as sam
jackson sam jackson can deliver a
classic angry and comical rant
even when he's playing an animated
character the incredibles
centers around a family of superheroes
and their superhero friends
including the jackson voice frozone who
has the ability to shoot ice out of his
hands
the superheroes are forced to hang up
their capes after some collateral damage
in lawsuits and they must now live
normal lives while disguised as everyday
citizens
but they of course hang on to their
capes and store them away just in case
naturally a villain starts terrorizing
the city and the public needs help
frozone is hanging out in his high-rise
apartment when he sees a giant robot
outside
prompting him to grab his super suit but
there's a little hiccup
his outfit is missing he seems to know
what happened to it because he instantly
asks his wife
honey what where's my super suit
the conversation develops into an
argument while the robot continues
blowing things up right outside the
window
frozone continues to demand to know
where his suit is but his wife has
something else on her mind
as they've been planning a nice dinner
date for two months when he insists that
the public is in danger
she responds
this golden moment of comedy was surely
already awesome on the page
but then sam jackson got a hold of it
and made it even more perfect
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one